both a little scared
neither one prepared beauty and the
beast
i think that i did it really
just for the fun of it and because i
thought my grandchildren would enjoy it
isn't that stupid
angela lansbury brought the iconic mrs
potts to life and the star behind the
voice of belle paige o'hara
every day
like the one before
what is the line of your characters that
you get requested or sent back to you
the most oh gosh without a doubt gaston
you're positively prime evil gaston you
are positively primeval
[Music]
only e.t got paige richard white who
played gaston and robbie benson the
voice of the beast back together for a
reunion robbie i don't know if you've
heard this before but lawrence fishburne
val kilmer and mandy patinkin all
considered for role of beast but you
beat them out there was a
long line of people who auditioned for
the part but uh yeah i guess i got lucky
are you
happy here with me no
are you happy here with me
and 30 years later it was thrilling
hearing paige bring belle back to life
there's something sweet and almost kind
but he was mean and he was coarse and
unrefined
now he's dear
and so unsure
i wonder why i didn't see it there
before
that's beautiful
[Music]
paige bell has some iconic outfits the
big yellow dress the blue apron dress
did you have any input on belle's
wardrobe
i did not but i loved it
i was secretly kind of excited about the
green dress as green's my favorite color
and that one nobody talks about that one
but that one moment when she's when the
beast opens her eyes in the library to
give her the library is actually one of
the most incredible moments i think in
the whole movie oh thank you so much
beauty and the beast was the first and
only animated film ever nominated for a
best picture oscar here
who is beautiful as me this was going to
last for the ages and i i felt that very
strongly at the time
[Music]
and for the film's end credits a
23-year-old celine dion and peebo bryson
sang the theme song it became a top 10
hit and won them a grammy
an honor
this song gave me a name in a way i'm
still singing that song on stage
[Music]
you